ladies and gentlemen I'm very pleased
prime minister that uh
welcome you here again to the Elysee for
this um bilateral Franco British Summit
the 36th in its format my thanks to you
and your ministers for the work
undertaken with all the teams to achieve
the common uh declaration which is a
robust piece of work and the excellent
discussions we had during the course of
the morning and um earlier with our
ministers five years have elapsed since
the last meeting between our two
governments and during those five years
our societies have gone through the
covid-19 pandemic seen the return of War
on our continent experiencing an energy
crisis return of inflation attorneys
five years the UK left the European
Union the 18th of January 2018 in
Sandhurst
I recall that there are two things that
nothing can change no vote no political
decision I would add now no pandemic
it's our history and our geography
they Place us together
in the face of a common Destiny it's
even true today we have a history that
binds us we have uh values that underpin
our solidarity friendship between our
peoples that sometimes have a
parenthesis on a soccer a rugby pitch I
don't want to go any further in sporting
discussions given what's uh looming but
we do have a geography that binds us
lastly and that's why um today this
Summit is indeed exceptional it's a
moment clearly I would say of a reunion
of reconnection and new beginning
it marks a shed will to speak to one
another to better coordinate and Build
Together new prospects in this context
and I believe that the will that you
clearly expressed and that we discussed
uh jointly together and what our
governments have worked on what we
manage to create the meetings with the
Business Leaders and the young leaders
goes in that direction the common
purpose that appeared to us is
self-evident in the new European and
international context that we're seeing
placing Europe faced with new
responsibility both of us uh permanent
members of the U.N security Council uh
NATO members equipped Powers with shared
interests we want to work together and
build Concrete Solutions for our future
in this respect and in this context I'd
like to welcome
um the new turn that was taken and your
resolve to re-engage with the EU and
congratulate you for the uh Windsor
framework that was uh concluded with the
President Van Der Lai now this uh New
Beginning we'd of course like to
continue and take full advantage of it
to coordinate more in support for
Ukraine I believe I can say we share the
same assessment the same result Russia
cannot and must not win this war we've
been helping Ukraine and the Ukrainian
people from day one to resist
humanitarily militarily and economically
and we're doing everything so that this
war doesn't uh spread globally we've
decided on concrete action together on
the training of um Ukrainian military
and high value segments and together we
want to prepare the coming weeks and
months with a shared conviction is that
we'll have to find an outcome to this
conflict we must play so Ukrainian
friends in the best possible situation
so they choose the moment of the and the
terms of the discussions that will have
to be led in the way we lead the
operations as a result to build a
lasting and acceptable peace in line
with international law and the interests
of the Ukrainian people a year to the
day in Versailles there was a major
European Council where we were defining
the terms of European strategic autonomy
and during which we affirmed that
Ukraine belonged to the European
European family this strategic autonomy
is also fought through a heightened need
to build
renewed ties with your countries in
terms of security and defense here we've
discussed at length here how to bolster
over and above the Russian
aggression in Ukraine and the con to
strengthen our shared capabilities to
work more on interrupt probability
operational Technical and humanite
thinking in particular of our result to
work ambitiously on the future anti-ship
missile the future Cruise Miss
interoperability of our future systems
and in areas as different as Mastery of
the seabed or energy directed weapons
and so the strengthening of these
capabilities is key and it's also that
that we wish to build to think also the
terms of tomorrow's European security to
have a genuine
legal framework and capabilities for our
anti-missile protection and to build
what will happen after the decisions
taken on you start you'll have
understood our commitment is to work now
for our continent in order to develop a
common strategy to strengthen our
cooperation do that in areas that are
absolutely key for our countries I'll
just cite a few
energy cooperation in this regard
there's some
cooperation wasn't impacted by brexit
it's bilateral it's strong
it's the fruit of profound choices that
you made of complementarity between
models nuclear with Hinckley pointsy and
the most visible operationalization of
cooperation in the sector size will see
that we support fully which would be an
opportunity for New Economic dynamism
and the result to continue this shared
projects in civilian nuclear power to
strengthen our projects and crossed
Investments we saw that once more this
morning in terms of renewable energy you
have expertise and capabilities that are
significant offshore win notably and to
have coordination in our low-carbon
hydrogen strategy I believe I can say
that our interests converge fully same
commitment on the environmental front
with a shared ambition accelerate our
exit from fossil fuels but also reform
our International Financial architecture
support against the fight of climate
change preparing the results of the
summit to be held in Paris on the 23rd
of June on the new Financial Pac
strengthen our joint commitments on
defending biodiversity and this through
the various milestones in the year the
end of year cop to finalize
joint uh achievements and in the fight
against illegal immigration we wish to
make progress in lockstep where face
aware of the human issues and the
extreme sensitivity of these issues
together we're already acting and I'd
like to thank you both our ministers and
all the teams who are working closely
together in 22 it's over 30
000 Small Boat Crossings that we
prevented we've dismantled 55 networks
of organized crime and made 500 arrests
thanks to the work of the joint Franco
British an intelligent Cell last October
we agreed on a renewed ambitious
bilateral framework to continue to fight
against illegal immigration today we've
decided to continue in that direction
very operationally concretely and
conscious of the shared nature of our
responsibility
respect what we've decided is um
heightened coordination on our
activities new initiatives compels
um each of us and we must act together
in a fully shared framework but also to
be able to do this with all the
Europeans who are concerned by the
transit and crossings and with them some
countries from which the traffic is
organized and in this regard the Calais
group
that's a relevant forum for coordination
of both our minutes there's a working
closely on that and they'll be holding
forthcoming meetings on that but we'd
also like to engage several countries of
origin involved in the illegal
trafficking networks we've agreed on the
need to heighten our intervention and
surveillance capabilities and we also
decided to strengthen multi-year funding
to commit some commensurate with the
current need on both sides and lastly
all the cooperation we've discussed
today
would be of not much use without
concrete actions to strengthen ties
between civil societies we met with
British and French businesses that are
invested in decarbonization issues we're
able to announce very tangible projects
and demonstrate through example this
complementarity this result to move
forward together we also met with young
Franco British talents looking very
promising and they will be the players
of our Anton called Yale it was very
title that they should be part and
parcel of this Summit and it's in that
same spirit that we've committed to
Greater cooperation between our Museum
our young our athletes our schools know
to be with a commitment to facilitate
school trips between our two countries
those are some of the issues of this
36th Franco British Summit but you'll
have understood that it wasn't a summit
like just any other and that given what
has happened these past few years and
that the time the planet and the
continent to living through it's a some
bit of a renewed ambition and before
even more ambitious concrete
achievements thank you prime minister
for being in Paris today
[Applause]
Manuel thank you for hosting us here
today now if we're honest the
relationship between our two countries
has had its challenges in recent years
and I'm not just referring to France
knocking England out of the World Cup
but I believe today's meeting does Mark
A New Beginning
and on taunt renewed we are looking to
the Future a future that builds on all
that we share our history our geography
our values
and a future that is far more ambitious
about how we work together to improve
the lives of the people that we serve
we've discussed every aspect of our
crucial Alliance today and made an
important progress in three areas in
particular illegal migration energy and
security
Emmanuel and I share the same belief
criminal gangs should not get to decide
who comes to our countries
within weeks of my coming into office we
agreed our largest ever small boat steel
and today we've taken our cooperation to
an unprecedented level to tackle this
shared challenge
we're announcing a new Detention Center
in northern France a new Command Center
bringing our enforcement teams together
in one place for the first time and an
extra 500 new offices patrolling French
beaches all underpinned by more drones
and other surveillance technologies that
will help ramp up the interception rate
and the legislation the UK has
introduced this week supports this
because it's designed to break the
business model of the criminal gangs and
remove the pull factors bringing them to
the channel Coast
now we will always comply with our
International treaty obligations but I
am convinced that within them that we
can do what is necessary to solve this
shared problem and stop the boats
second the UK and France are working
together so that never again can the
likes of Putin weaponize our energy
security
you are helping us to secure our supply
of nuclear power thanks to EDS
incredible work at sideswell C and
through our ports and interconnectors we
can be Europe's Gateway for non-russian
gas but today we are going even further
with an ambitious new energy partnership
we've signed a new deal on civil nuclear
cooperation agreed that France will
examine the case for new energy
interconnectors and committed to work
together on low carbon energy together I
believe we are creating a future where
every watt of energy powering our homes
and Industry will come from secure
sustainable and reliable sources
third the UK and France
share a special bond
and a special responsibility
when the security of our continent is
threatened we will always be at the
Forefront of its defense
and today we're going even further to
strengthen our security and defense
cooperation
we've agreed to train Ukrainian Marines
helping to give Ukraine a decisive
advantage on the battlefield and for
Ukraine to win this war
to increase the interoperability of our
forces harnessing the full potential of
the combined joint expeditionary Force
to promote security and stability in the
indo-pacific coordinating our carrier
deployment and we will jointly explore
the development of complex weapons like
air defense combat air and long-range
weapons
now for decades we've been two of the
world's biggest defense powers and
leading contributors to Nato
and we will continue to stand together
for Freedom democracy and the rule of
law
finally today there has also been a
celebration of the richness
of our cultures all that we give to each
other and all that we learn from each
other so we've agreed to make it easier
for our children to go on school
exchanges and our Museum creators
writers and artists to create and
collaborate together
and that brings me to my concluding
thought
that for all the agreements that we've
reached today in the end it's about
people
the bonds of family
friendship and solidarity that we share
and there's no greater example of that
human connection
than the sympathy of the French people
on the passing
of her majesty the queen
and I want to thank you personally
Emmanuel for the graciousness of your
words
they said everything about you as a
leader and as a friend of Britain
you know I've learned very quickly in
this job that there are some things you
can control and some things that you
can't
and one thing that you can't control is
who you get as an international
counterpart
I feel very fortunate to be serving
alongside you and Incredibly excited
about the future that we can build
together Monami
[Applause]
thank you
Mr President prime minister of the
journalists
thank you Chris bison from BBC News the
same question to you both if I may do
you think you'll ever be able to arrange
a deal where migrants leaving France for
the UK are returned to France
thank you yeah I'll take that thanks uh
Chris I think what you've seen today is
an unprecedented level of cooperation on
tackling this share challenge because
that's what it is it's a sure challenge
it's not just the UK that's grappling
with illegal migration it's not just
France countries across Europe and our
partnership is incredibly strong I think
the work that our two home secretaries
sweller and Gerard have done over the
past few months has been unlike anything
that anyone's ever seen and you're
seeing the fruits of that cooperation
today with a new agreement new
investment and that will help both of us
stop the cycle of these criminal gangs
and going forward there will be more
that we can do we started that last
November we've built on it today and
we'll continue cooperating as as the
president said and he'll probably talk
about the Calais group is another
important forum for these conversations
to happen with other northern European
countries and I'm sure Emmanuel probably
will talk a little bit about the EPC and
as we think about future cooperation
between the UK and other countries in
Europe what the president has set up is
a new forum for that engagement to
happen in the legal migration I'm
certain will be one of the topics that
we will discuss when we come to that
meeting that will be pleased to host
next year in the UK and obviously is
happening this year elsewhere
yes thank you for your question
um first I think we focus on what we
have to do on the short run to prevent
precises migrations and to try to
dismantle all these these groups these
networks and these models and and I
think the level of ambition of this new
plan is exactly what we need
this is what we can do on the at the
bilateral level second this is not an
agreement between UK and France but an
agreement between Yuki and the EU
because Dublin agreement are no more in
a situation to be implemented so this is
something now to be negotiated
third as Mr Prime Minister just further
said uh
we do believe that the right way to
approach this migrations
is a broader space
Western Balkans European union and not
just France and UK
have to work closely together in order
precisely
to dismantle these groups and to be more
efficient regarding this phenomenon and
this is why it's part of the key topics
we have to discuss
in the framework of this European
political community and our perspective
is to have concrete discussion in June
in kisi now in Moldova and indeed
next semester we will have in Spain and
the semester after in UK so we want to
follow up
the foreign
Ukraine you spoke about the conditions
to be created for a future peace are you
on the same wavelength when it comes to
the necessity of an negotiation Mr
sunlight you shared this idea of the
president
on your first question there's a
tendency there isn't new in the Kremlin
which is to consider that any population
movement is manipulation coming from
outside because the Deep conviction is
that in fact there's no public opinion
or no free people we are entitled as an
old democracy to believe the opposite
and so
I won't describe what has happened but
we mustn't lapse into that rather
summary explanation however Georgia
today is
um
affected by worrisome movements and we
saw
um images these past few days wearing a
young woman carrying the
um European flag who was uh
pushed around to put it mildly on that
cannot leave us in different uh as both
of us as Europeans
resolve is to assist Europe public
opinions as freely as possible to
express their views in countries to
conduct in a sovereign fashion the
course of their existence Georgia is
subject to very strong pressure and I
hope it can find the path to Greater
calmness which is uh compatible with the
European prospect that we held out to it
I would add also in this regard
the peacemaking initiatives be taken by
the government former political leaders
held
um in poor health should be released so
that we can take into account their
state of health and that the situation
is becomes calmer in regard to uh
tensions will return to that in the
coming weeks for Ukraine short term our
goal is to help Ukraine conduct the
counter-offensive that it wishes to
conduct the priority as military I've
always said for my part that our
Prospect was indeed that there should be
a lasting pill
forged in um conditions that um Ukraine
will choose and our duty is to place it
in that situation
agree with Emmanuel so let me just be
unequivocal about this we want Ukraine
to win this war and we're absolutely
United in that and right now
that means providing them with the
support and the capabilities in the
training in order to mount a
counter-offensive and have decisive
advantage on the battlefield and that's
what you've seen from the UK from France
from other allies whether it's through
the provision of main battle tanks
longer range weapons as we've announced
today training of Marines these are all
things that will help Ukraine win this
war gain that advantage on the
battlefield mount a successful
counter-offensive and that's what we are
channeling all our energies towards and
with regard to the future I think agree
with what Emanuel just said there
ultimately that is a decision for
Ukraine to make it's not a decision for
us to make for them our job is to put
Ukraine in the strongest possible
position and that is what our
conversations today have been about
that's what our defense ministers spend
enormous amount of time coordinating and
I think actually that the announcements
that you've seen from us today are out
training Marines helping with the
provision of ammunition of very tangible
examples of our commitment to deliver
Ukraine that advantage and that is where
all our focus is going to be over the
coming weeks and months
uh Oliver Wright from the times prime
minister
um the UK has already spent around 300
million pounds supporting French efforts
to stem small boats but the boats have
kept coming uh the UK is now promising
around 500 billion pounds more
um what makes you think that this money
will be any more effective and president
macron of ma
um do you think Britain and France can
ever be as close as they were before
brexit
I'll take your first one I think just a
couple of things it I think you
described it as as French efforts let's
just be clear these are joint efforts
right that's the first thing to
recognize these are efforts by our teams
jointly on the ground to tackle what is
a shared Challenge and that's the first
thing to get across so now you talk to
terms about our previous investment
actually Emmanuel mentioned it in his
remarks right 50 different criminal
gangs broken almost 500 arrests made and
just this year thousands of boats
stopped right that is that is the result
of a partnership that is working and is
delivering now is the situation still
challenging of course it is right and
that's because there is a global
migration problem that we are seeing the
impact of on our Shores and across
Europe and as we saw recently tragically
people dying off the coast of Italy now
there are Global forces at play but we
are working incredibly hard to try and
break that cycle and I think the
cooperation that we've had and
especially since last November has
really made a difference and the
announcements that we've made today will
make an even bigger difference going
forward and I've always been clear
there's no one solution to solving this
very complicated problem and nor will it
be solved overnight right but there's
you know our new legislation will help
and I've always had cooperation with our
allies especially France is an important
part of that and but where we can make
investments alongside Emmanuel and
France we're not things alone we're
jointly investing in all these
operations or indeed Upstream to disrupt
criminal crime gangs whether it's in the
Balkans or elsewhere those are good
Investments for the UK to make if they
stop people coming and and reduce the
pressure on our Asylum system in our
hotels and I actually think today's
agreements represent a very positive
step forward and the level of
cooperation and integration is going to
make a difference and I think we are
confident our teams are confident that
you're going to see the benefit of that
on the ground and that's what we're
going to deliver
look um
this is my wish but it depends on what
we will do in the coming months and
years
on the short run what we have to do is
to fix the consequences of the brexit a
lot of issues we have are direct
consequences of a brexit and probably
some of these consequences were
underestimated that we have to fix them
second we have to deal with the
consequences of this war and the new
geopolitical context
but what we want to do is now to build
new Partnerships
on defense and security facing the war
regarding climate change in order to
better coordinate our International
activity and for all businesses and our
people we want to build new links
new relations and indeed this European
political communities one of those
framework I think this is a very
relevant political framework to build
something new at the level of the
continent
My Wish definitely because it's it makes
sense with our history our geography our
DNA I would say
is to have the best I mean the best
possible relation and the closest
Alliance
but it will depend on our commitment our
willingness
but I'm sure we will do it
last question
Mr President bfm TV both your countries
are confronted to important social
movements have you together spoken about
this question uh related to inflation
did you evoke this question and the
mechanism to fight inflation and Mr
macron the reform of the real time and
you've said in a letter to the trade
unions today that the MPS represent the
plurality of the opinions in our country
if your project doesn't receive the
majority amongst the members of
parliament would you exclude to pass it
through force and use article 49 3 for
the reform that you're seeking
thank you for that question the
situation that our countries are
experiencing creates a lot of difficulty
for many of our fellow citizen inflation
energy food prices
cost of living creating very challenging
situations in
um All European countries for our fellow
citizens and that's why for that matter
since uh the Autumn of 2021 we have a
Resolute policy of support on Energy
prices now on food prices by covering a
great many of the spending items for the
those with financial difficulties and
pushing authorities to assume their
difficulties with them organizing
agreements with retailers the strong
Vigilant strong commitment look at the
figures of France with uh peers we
remain uh one of the countries with the
lowest inflation rate because of the
policies was implemented there were
demonstrations as part of the pensions
reform I won't engage in any fictional
politics here it's not my role there was
a time for Union negotiation then was
say a time during which the executive
work and then there's the Parliamentary
time at the house and the Senate the
Senate is working flat out both day and
night to review the bill we must respect
that parliamentary time without
um in any way crafting any uh possible
scenarios of fiction of whatever sort I
let the senator his work with the
government and then the parliament will
follow the terms of our constitution so
that the legislation process can be
completed neither more nor less and that
in a climate of calm of respect for
agreements disagreements and a sense of
responsibility in the current context
I think when you you talk about
inflation and the cost of living the
biggest driver of that inflation is
Energy prices right it's because we've
had a war that has weaponized energy
supplies and all of our citizens are
paying the price for that and actually
that's one of the very practical
tangible things to come out of today's
Summit is that cooperation between our
two countries and our businesses on
improving our energy security and
accelerating the transition to renewable
nuclear and more secure energy supplies
now I I'm more confident that we can
make that happen as a result of today's
Summit because of the partnership
between our researchers our businesses
our governments we are going to be able
to get our citizens cheaper more secure
more renewable and cleaner energy faster
and that's what people should come away
from this seeing that actually these
things can make a big difference for the
citizens that we're both very privileged
to represent we want to ease the
pressures on cost of living for them the
way to do that is to diversify and
improve our supply of energy and
accelerate that transition to Net Zero
and we've made good progress on that
goal um today and maybe you know that's
a thought that I can close on a little
bit it goes to the previous question you
know that's a tangible example of the
relationship that we have
and you can see that today in the
comprehensive nature of the discussions
the breadth of the discussions the depth
of discussions the fact that we both got
our senior teams all here today talking
through these issues
um you know I always say we left the EU
but we didn't leave Europe
and you know Emmanuel said previously
you know brexit didn't change geography
right we we want to have a closed
Cooperative collaborative relationship
with our European partners and allies
and of course that starts with our
nearest neighbor France and today is the
first step on that Journey we're writing
a new chapter in this relationship and
I'm really looking forward to everything
that we can build on in the coming
months and years ahead
thank you very much
thank you so much
okay well there you have Richardson I
can Emmanuel macron speaking of a
wide-ranging summit between the UK and
France both leaders heralding a new
chapter in UK French relations today's
meeting does Mark A New Beginning said
Rishi sunak the French leader is saying
it is a moment of reunion of
reconnection and of a new beginning
Let's uh speak to Deputy Deputy
political editor Sam coats who was in
that Hall
um Sam that's exactly what it sounds
like doesn't it a new era of
anglo-french relations
that's what they're telling us and uh
the Anton renewed was the language from
Rishi sunak and to be honest president
macron talked also of the Anton called
cordial that famous early 20th century
uh agreement and you can see behind me
we have the ceremonial guard who have uh
just lined up outside the door of the
Elise Palace Simon case the cabinet
secretary visible just through the glass
door because we expect Rishi sunak to
come out with president macron in a few
moments in order to say uh goodbye we
can see a little bit of activity just
through the glass door but what was
important for Rishi sunak was to be seen
to be changing the conversation with
France with Europe more generally and in
order to do that and here is the prime
minister finishing that conversation
after an important day of diplomacy for
Britain uh he would regard this perhaps
as the most important today is perhaps
the most important symbol of Britain's
changed approach to
you have the two leaders there president
macron holding the umbrella for Rishi
knackers they enjoy a last bit of solo
conversation and posing for the cameras
foreign
the two men sharing much they're both in
some senses quite similar economic
backgrounds in some would call both
technocrats not necessarily from the
most ideological wings of their party uh
both brought in off the back of quite a
difficult and turbulent times uh for uh
their respective countries to try and uh
to try and calm things down and uh both
men trying to now improve the
conversation uh between the two
countries
um what's interesting though is the
difference between the tone and the
substance because I think there's no
doubt that when uh President macron says
it wasn't just another Summit you could
feel that they that they meant it from
the amount of time they spent together
from the way in which they talk very
warmly about one another but what Rishi
Cena has to do we were talking about
this before the press conference is
she's got to show that this new approach
approach delivers and at the heart of
what we learned during that press
conference it's quite interesting the
way that they did it behind the scenes
they released all the detail of exactly
what's been negotiated just as the two
men stood up to speak so you'll have
been watching the press conference and
there you can see Richie sunak has now
left the Elysee Palace and in a moment
you'll see uh president macron walking
back inside uh the um the Elysee here he
is holding his
umbrella with a uh with his military
attache waving to Sky News viewers as he
does so and then heading back inside the
visit concluded so while as they stood
up into all of our inboxes came the
details of the negotiation uh that has
been going on behind the scenes today
and and that actually was quite telling
in itself so the headline that number 10
want you to read about in the morning is
that for the first time Britain is going
to fund a Detention Center in northern
France in order to deal with the issue
of small boats so that is going to be
presented I think by the British
government as a major win in the fight
against trying to stop those small boats
from crossing the channel now as it
happens there are quite a lot of
questions about who exactly will put the
migrants in the Detention Center under
what Authority given that the police
have not really detained French police
haven't detained the migrants before and
where exactly they will go after being
in the Detention Center since France
doesn't have a kind of Rwanda removals
policy in the same way that Britain is
attempting to so that's the headline the
details uncertain but then there's a big
butt and it came far far down the media
release that we saw which is that the
amount of money that the UK is going to
transfer pay France in order to try and
get help tacking the small base is
absolutely extraordinary it's
astronomical so to give you some context
between 2014 and this year Britain has
spent cumulatively across all those
years all those nine years about a
quarter of a billion pounds about 250
million pounds has been given to France
to tackle small boats and toughen up
border security in this deal across the
next three years that's going to jump to
about half a billion pounds about 500
million pounds roughly just under 500
million is what the the government's
going to be paying France in order to
break up the boat unclear what the
powers are and clear the man in which
they'll do it unclear that there will be
more than the current roughly 50 success
rate that the French have so that's kind
of that's that's one of the biggest
thing that's been negotiated uncertain
how it worked it'll cost a lot
um as ever with these things that what
really matters is whether it ends up
working people end up end up thinking
that this was uh money well spent uh I
suspect there will be some eyebrows
raised on the conservative back benches
about the decision to transfer money on
that scale in order to in order to deal
with this problem but it is a deal it is
a deal that Richie sunac has hammered
out and is prepared to stand behind uh I
think that uh so I think that will be
certainly one of the more controversial
elements of that
but I think more than anything else for
Richie see that he wanted to put the
last few years behind him he said if
we're being honest the relationship has
had its challenges uh I want a new
beginning it is an on taunt renewed that
message has been sent that message has
been recognized by the French President
and now Rishi sunak is going to head
Elsewhere on the world stage to deliver
that to make out he is the grown-up in
his world to draw a contrast with his
predecessors and to suggest that Britain
is back as a diplomatic force and it'll
be for the country to to judge whether
or not it delivers what he intends
okay Sam thank you so much uh Sam
outside the Elysee Palace there let's
bring in Agnes Parlier now she's a
French journalist she's also in Paris
Agnes you were listening to that press
conference what did you make of it
well it was very interesting to uh
listen first to president Macos who
spoke first but also wishes to knock
after him who really uh stressed uh how
much of a reset that quanco British
Summit uh was in in the bilateral
relation uh Richard sunak talked about
the crucial Alliance and uh and
President Michael was also uh you know
rather eloquent when he said no matter
what
um you know whether it's a pandemic or
whether it's a referendum like brexit
there are two things that are never
going to change our history and our
geography and we are bound together by
uh common values and common Destiny
which is a strong
um word
um so you know as expected
um that is back on the table
um and uh and also both governments
actually uh behind doors the in the last
few weeks even months prepare that
Summit uh very much and and in depth and
we're just now given the details as some
was alluding to
um the details of what has been
um agreed what is interesting too is
that prison Michael uh listed uh the the
different themes uh the different you
know he started with Ukraine uh talking
about defense of course and energy and
only came to Illegal migration
um as a fourth or fifth point in his
list just before uh talking about school
trips and further coordination and
partnership with museums for instance I
was Rishi Suna talked first about the
small boats uh because of course it's uh
extremely important uh in Britain and uh
for domestic politics
um but all in all it's it's really a
reset you know that both men press the
button together and
um and when you change the mood tone uh
the the Moon music uh when uh you know
you behave differently and you respect
the the other's point of view then you
can achieve the uh you know great things
also as both men stressed
um in five years a lot of things have
happened in the world and uh and not
only kovid of course they were talking
about a war on the European continent
Ukraine for which both countries now
have to uh show that as President
Michael said they share the same
conviction the same assessment and the
same result uh so we'll we will
hopefully
um see more of as a Franco British
joint
voice on the subject of Ukraine which is
good for Europe
one of the the issues is that the UK has
spent a lot of money on this issue of
the illegal Boat Crossings and this new
deal
is a staggering amount
of money as well Millions more going in
he says well in the release it says the
French will contribute significantly
more funding when are we going to learn
do you think just how much the French
are going to contribute here
well that's what I was going to say the
French contributes quite a lot of money
and French taxes payers uh pain to it as
well I don't have the figures uh it
would be interested interesting to uh to
look at it but uh you know there's a new
Command Center which never was allowed
before by uh by the French so this is a
I think uh really a successful which is
to not badly manage to convince to come
to thought to have such uh um uh joint
Command Center in France also this new
Detention Center
um and drones uh Paul's the surveillance
of 30 30 kilometers of Coastline
um I mean it implies a lot of resources
and resources mean a lot of money
um so you know but but it's not
something uh and the two men were really
stressing it
um it's it's now gone beyond a Franco
British issue and uh there's this forum
the Cali Forum that has been set up and
also Britain needs now to negotiate a
deal with the EU about about returning
migrants because uh brexit has happened
since and uh this is the way forward and
they also talked about
um bringing in the discussion the
countries of origin where uh the the
migrants come from
um they didn't talk about processing
Asylum Seekers application from France
but that's another route
um so you know there's no instant
solution uh to this problem